[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday the 28th of
july i'm kate andrews the spectators
economics editor and your host this week
on this week's show
we're now a fortnight into the tory
leadership race rishi sunak is still
behind can he catch up i'll speak to
katie balls and tim stanley and then be
joined by james forsyth for your latest
political updates
charles moore interviewed rishi sunak
for this week's magazine we'll have a
teaser of their discussion
charles parton writes in this week's
magazine that while the west is finally
coming to understand the threats posed
by china we're still not talking about
one of the most serious risks the
internet of things he'll join to explain
and finally has the right gone too far
in its retaliation to the culture wars
i'll speak to douglas murray
a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever before as a new
subscriber joining today you'll pay just
one pound a week for unlimited online
and app access in your first year to
subscribe today go to spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash tv offer
and why not subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
ballots for tory party members to elect
the next prime minister will go out next
week with liz trust still leading rishi
sunak in the polls could the race be
over before it ever really even began
katie balls writes in this week's cover
piece that rishi sunak is doing a mad
dash to win over the membership to
explain she joins me now alongside the
telegraph's tim stanley
katie tim thanks for joining me katie
write in the cover piece for this week's
magazine about rishi sunax mad dash to
catch up with liz truss in the polls
tell us about it well i think it's
pretty uphill for richie sooneck at the
moment
um now he had been talked up as a front
runner um there was a brief period where
he's talked of someone who never entered
downing street straight after the nom
dom scandal involving his wife but i
think in recent weeks
he has been seen as the one to beat
particularly he look at the fact he had
the you know the most parliamentary
support
and i think he's also had quite a slick
campaign lots of volunteers and assumed
very organized um and i think the idea
was even though he was slightly behind
the grass roots uh his supporters
thought he'd have the whole summer to
effectively campaign and this would play
well to his strengths because he's a
good communicator so therefore head to
heads hustings lots of debates and media
and that would mean that he could you
know slowly and ever way at his rival
whom we now know as liz trust the
problem well the ballots go out next
week
and the expectation is that tory members
will vote pretty quickly and they are
unlikely to sit on these forms all
summer and therefore by next weekend you
could have a situation where the contest
is at least
largely decided um now there is a way
that uh members can vote twice and the
final vote counts um and there's been
some alarms saying well this means that
it could all change but this is only
done uh online and therefore i think
there's skepticism in both camps and
this is really going to be um you know
exercise that's taken up by many and it
means that rishi sooner is now in a race
against time we know according to the
latest yougov poll that liz trust has a
lead of over 20 points and it means what
can he do to erode that and i think he
is running out of ways to change the
dial in this leadership contest
tim as katie points out there sunak has
far less time than he expected to win
over the membership do you think it's
even possible now for him to catch up
i don't know if it is i i think katie's
piece is fantastic and her analysis was
absolutely spot on i just want to say
that as well as as being about rishi's
weaknesses
it's also about liz's growing strengths
and she has two things that really work
for her
one is that i think she's actually
improved
if if sunax team hoped that in the
course of these debates liz would be
exposed as as wooden and stiff and a bad
debater and rishi is a really good one
but i think we've actually seen liz
trust get better as the as the debates
have gone on she's retained some of that
charming robotic body language i keep
talking in my sketches about her holding
an invisible tea tray she's always
holding her hands out like this but
nonetheless she's really getting very
good at interjecting and fighting and
standing her own ground so i think trust
has grown in strength as a candidate but
the other strength she has which again
is a weakness for rishi sunak is that
the central issue of this campaign is
tax
it's the central issue partly because
it's just about economics and how much
money is in people's pocket in an era of
a cost of living squeeze people want to
retain more of their own money but it
also goes to the heart of the question
of what are the tories about
are they a party which is rishi sees it
balances the books are good public
servants administrators or as trust sees
it are they a party that actually tries
to change things either to grow the
economy shrink the estate or
in introduce some of that dynamic
capitalism that's been missing in the
last few years so i don't know if rishi
sunet can turn much around because i i
think those two things liz truss's
actual underlying strengths which have
been underappreciated and also the
central issue of tax i'm not sure rishi
can
overcome those two problems katie what
do you make of tim's point there that a
problem for rishi sunek is that liz
trust is actually exceeding expectations
yeah i mean i think tim makes a really
interesting point and actually if you
look at liz truss's entire career i
think she has spent a lot of that being
underestimated by her colleagues and you
look at some of the earlier briefs where
she did make mistakes um but it almost
led to
i think quite an anti-liz trust
contingent in parliament i think
particularly among some of the mps who
came at the same time of her and they've
often felt that she's been over promoted
and i think that actually really since
um probably the 2017 snap election
um i think that was a turning point for
liz trust because effectively it looked
as though should be put in political
siberia there's a sense that theresa may
would win this large majority i think
liz trust and sagittarius were the two
who would probably face the acts in her
victory reshuffle now and teresa it was
too weak to sack anyone but i think it
meant that liz trust actually started to
take risks in her ministerial career as
a reminder that these things could end
at any moment and then as chief
secretary of the treasury but then later
i think particularly international trade
under boris johnson and then as foreign
secretary i i do think that she has
surprised some of her colleagues and has
earned
respect that was perhaps lacking earlier
on now i think this does lead to the
sense where employees look at liz trust
and they do underestimate and some of
that has happened here as tim says the
past few media performers have been an
improvement on the first i still think
that richard cena is a more assured
media performer but actually and
speaking to some members last night i
was at the talk tv debate that was cut
short and arthur was cut short you had a
situation where um liz trust and rishi
sunak went through to speak with some of
the audience and speaking to the members
afterwards i mean they were actually
pretty nice about both of them but a few
of them did say they found rishi scenic
polished in a way that they they liked
that liz trust was a bit less polished
and and i think that is one of the
things that has perhaps been
underestimated in this race the fact
that at the moment at least and these
things can change quickly just remember
when we said uh you know theresa may was
good that she didn't socialize much in
the bars and that did become a problem
but right now um i think some of uh liz
truss's awkwardness because it's viewed
as authentic is actually working in her
favor
and it means when it comes to rishi's
unix campaign strategy as tim said it's
been so largely faced on the economy and
they tried to do something where um they
tried to make his tax position which is
ultimately something which has been a
source of frustration with many tory mps
and members in into a plus even though
it is in many ways a negative and
initially i think it meant the debate
was saw lots of candidates almost
tripping over themselves to cut taxes in
a point that it started quite
irresponsible for some of those pledges
which worked for rishi sunak but now i
think the risk is that he sounds quite
negative and pessimistic against liz
trust who sounds optimistic um now we
can query at the wisdom of liz trust's
plans and lots of people are but
speaking to mps they say that the
offering the membership um everyone's
you know they'll vote with their hearts
not their heads on this and i think liz
trust is tapping into something that
richard is struggling to at the moment
for some of those reasons what we can
expect from this campaign now i think is
to do a lot more media to do uh
antifreeze more policies in in a bid to
turn the tide but i think once you get
momentum behind a campaign and one seems
to be lacking it is a much harder job to
turn things
tim you mentioned that the more the
public is seeing of trust the more they
may be liking her but she still doesn't
want to be overexposed and i'm thinking
about how she's copying boris johnson in
her approach to decline being
interviewed by andrew neal where she's
cenac of course is going to do that sit
down one-on-one interview what do you
make of both their choices to do that
from a journalist's point of view i'm
obviously greatly offended and upset
that she won't speak to andrew from a
politician's point of view i think
that's the smartest thing she could
possibly do because he's very very good
and you take a great risk with that
you've got to wear it up in your head
and say what do i gain by doing it there
is a slim chance that i might do well
enough for a handful of voters to say
liz came out of that relatively
unscathed but it doesn't really gain you
any momentum it's a much larger risk
that you're going to do badly and you're
going to end up losing voters by
contrast rishi sunak okay he he probably
should do it because he's smooth and
capable and i'm sure he'll come across
well
i don't know how again if that'll be a
big game changer for him though because
people who are looking for that kind of
polish and competence are probably
already drawn towards rishi sunak and
his brand they don't necessarily
they won't necessarily change their
minds on the basis of that interview um
i think
both of them that they're going to have
different media strategies because as
katie has laid out rishi needs to
introduce himself to the public win them
over and remind them why he already
looks like a prime minister but from liz
truster's point of view i think it's
wise to run a viet cong style guerrilla
campaign meet the members impress them
stress that you are philosophically at
one with them
and i think that's far more likely to
win
katie speaking of boris johnson there
you write in your piece that sue next
team think that the conservative
membership support for liz trust
is softer not nearly as committed to her
as they were for boris johnson can you
explain yeah i think
i think we're at the point in this race
where obviously the don't knows matter a
lot because when we're talking about
their uh that over 20 point need um that
liz trust enjoys every rishi soon act
that excludes don't knows and therefore
where do they go
and i think looking even at some of liz
trusted supporters there is a sense that
they are not wedded to liz trust in the
way that boris johnson inspired a loyal
following and that's partly i think
because of of two things first i think
liz trust is less well-known than boris
johnson was she is not seen as you know
as big a character she hasn't presented
have i got news for you she wasn't
london mayor so while she's held senior
cabinet positions and um you know is the
longest serving member continuously of
the cabinet um
she i think we've seen different sides
of her and it means that the public are
learning things about liz trust so
there's less to be wedded to in a very
loyal manner and then secondly i think
there also points to a general lack of
enthusiasm in this contest and that's
partly because uh we saw in the
membership polling that the
candidates who were lesser known and by
that i mean the fresher-faced candidates
so kemi badenock even penny morden to a
degree and there was quite a lot of
enthusiasm for them and i think the
sense of let's get a fresh face someone
who's not wedded to uh you know any of
the
scandal or tricky decisions or even
psycho drama of the boris johnson
government
um and now that has not been offered to
the membership
i think as much as they're saying liz
trust has an edge on rishi soon act i
think it's safe to say that some members
are not inspired by either candidate and
that means there is quite a lot of
indecision which could mean in a way
that some of the members don't vote
straight away i think that's something
that we we just don't know yet but if
you're not 100 sure you could sit on
that form for a while
tim that's an interesting point that
there's a lack of enthusiasm because of
a lack of new and fresh faces also
perhaps there's a lack of enthusiasm
because you know if you look around you
know we're going into some pretty
difficult times economically the you
know whether or not we officially go
into recession is one thing but a lot of
people are going to feel like we're in
recession because we're forecast to have
essentially no growth for years to come
inflation is nearing double digits uh
real wages are falling
these are really tough times whoever
gets this job whether it be sunac or
truss
is not going to waltz into number 10 in
the way that boris did sure he could get
a brexit deal over the line and you know
of course we didn't know what was about
to hit a few months later with a massive
pandemic that there was a real sense of
optimism at the start of boris johnson's
premiership like there was all to play
for you know anything could be done um
very different this time around
whoever gets this job is in for a really
tough few years
you're right first of all 2019 was a
do-over it was a chance to remake
politics with a new majority it almost
felt like a new conservative party more
boris johnson's party certainly than
david cameron's
and the lockdown and pandemic changed
all of that it changed the economic
equation it pushed brexit out and now
we're back to discussing to come back to
tax so back to discussing the
fundamentals
of government and how you get an economy
to grow in this situation among the mps
i speak to a lot of them are quite
despondent you've got to remember that a
third roughly a third voted for rishi
sumac
roughly a third voted for liztross and
roughly a third voted for penny mordent
in other words neither trust nor sunak
really have a
big substantial lead among mps now of
course they're drawing people back to
them
and within their campaign says
enthusiasm because those people believe
in that candidate but there's a
significant number of mps now who
believe that it is likely that they will
lose the election in the next two years
and that's because of the economic
picture that you've painted but also
because boris johnson has done so much
damage to the reputation of the tory
party
and they're already starting to think
about who will be leader of the
opposition they're already started
looking at those candidates who didn't
come through kemi badenock uh sowella
braverman tom tugan had and they're
wondering who is the person who can lead
us out lead us back into government
in the election after the next by and
large they they don't think that we're
going to see a massive labor majority
you're likely to get a labor minority
propped up perhaps by the smp's votes or
by coalition with the lib dems or
something like that but people are
coming to terms with the fact that the
economy is bad politics is not going the
way of the conservatives right now and
they have to prepare for two very
difficult years in which case
psychologically perhaps what we're
voting for here is a caretaker leader
someone who can see them through those
two years and actually if the two
candidates the one who to me
tries to buck that narrative the most is
liz truss she is the one who says that
we have to change everything if we're
going to survive whereas rishi sunak uh
partly because he's playing the
competence card and again partly because
of his position on tax is coming across
as the continuity candidate and i think
there are a lot of mps a lot of members
who think that's not good enough
and yet katie last question to you rishi
sunak is putting forward the idea that
he is the only one based on current
polling that could beat kiyostama in a
general election
that was a big point that he was using
with the mps when he was trying to
secure their votes he's still using it
now but is it having the same effect on
the grassroots
well i think it's interesting to go back
to tim's point
ultimate in a way the crux of the matter
is
what went wrong in the past few months
that led to boris johnson to resign
isn't boris johnson
was the wrong person to be leader in the
sense he became so modern scandal
and he couldn't get number 10 to
function in a way that was delivering
the 2019 manifesto um that things have
gone wrong
and therefore you just need someone who
can actually deliver that manifesto a
manifesto that won a majority in the
region of 80. um yes you had jeremy
corbyn uh yes she had brexit and that
will help towards the majority but
effectively i think there are quite a
lot of tory mps who think that manifesto
is broadly in the right place and this
realignment of politics um you want to
stay estate broadly in that area in
order to continue it and therefore do
you just need a leader who
avoids the scandal who's seen as fairly
competent and you stay on that road and
that's how you win re-election because
that is what that is one school's
thought in the tory party right now or
as tim uh points to do you need someone
who's gonna tear things up and actually
um
go further try different things and and
i think that debate is still playing out
in the party
um if you think about
i think some of the policies on on tax
and direction the cost of living in
crisis exacerbating it so that is one
part of it and then i think in terms of
electability
i think that there are lots of tory mps
who think that liz trusts will not win
them the next election
and i think there are tory mps who worry
that the membership is not thinking
along the same lines as they are and
their and ultimately their seats will be
at risk if it is not rishi zunak um
and
there is not really a way at the moment
to make all those things come together
and it means we are heading for an
uncertain period i've definitely spoken
to tory mps i would say i would say more
tory mps are worried about the next
election under liz trust than rishi
sunak now there are plenty of tory mps
who think unless you cut taxes you're
not going to win the next election too
and actually think that one of the most
important things are probably under
appreciated about liz truster's tax plan
is it gets you to a point where you can
say you didn't break a manifesto pledge
and trust is going to be really
important in the next election so if you
undo the national insurance height
because she says she will do that will
stand them in good stead um
and that means that richie's next
message is landing well in some parts of
the country and i think we'll see some
of that with some of the membership
polling too in the sense of what is the
breakdown here um so it holds potency
with some i think with others they just
disagree with her strategy and never is
quite a murky picture and it's hard i
think it's becoming harder for richie to
say particularly because this trust is
faring better in the debates it's hard
to say electoral disaster for this
person would meet with me huge success
and then finally i would just say that
the thing that is making it quite tricky
for risky night 2 is this betrayal
narrative that's slowly being built when
it comes to the demise of boris johnson
now
if we looked at membership polling and
again pulling all the pinch assault as
ever ahead of boris johnson resigning
the membership appeared to be turning on
boris johnson but there are still parts
of the membership who are loyal to boris
johnson and angry um along with some
voters that he was pushed out
and the fact that boris johnson making
such little you know he's not really
hiding the fact that he holds rishi soon
like part perhaps as being kind
responsible rather than the series of
scandals which i think you could also
point to um does mean speaking to mps
they find that talking to the membership
it's it's not the first thing they say
but it's just adding some suspicion to
rishi's student as a candidate which
means his mount to climb is becoming
even trickier
katie tim thanks for joining me on
spectator tv
now let's look ahead to the future
challenges that the next prime minister
will face i'm joined by james forsyth
the spectator's political editor
james thanks for joining me in your
politics column for the magazine this
week you talk about how whether it's a
prime minister sunac or a prime minister
trust this autumn is going to be really
difficult for whoever enters 10 downing
street tell us why
so energy prices are you know shortly
before the new uh pm takes office off
general announced how much the energy
cap is going up by in october and it
looks like it's going to go up by a lot
and i think the worry is that energy
prices show no sign of coming down and i
think this winter is going to be very
very difficult uh
there is
absolutely no way that i can see how
europe can fill up its gas storage over
in the coming months to prepare it for
autumn and so i think you will see the
russians play with turning up and down
the flow trying to kind of create an
energy crisis in in europe that is gonna
you know the uk is not dependent on
russian gas in the way that some
european countries are most noticeably
germany but that will push up the prices
of energy here
that i mean and then that is going to
contribute to inflation
inflation is going to carry on going up
and that is what makes everybody poorer
and politics very scratchy
uh then you've got the situation with
the nhs uh i think this winter could be
has a potential to be one of the worst
winter crises in the nhs uh in uh in
living memory um you look at the fact
that west midlands ambulance service
expects to spend 48 000 hours this month
waiting to discharge patients into
hospitals um you look at the fact that
the director of nursing at the
westminster ambulance service is warning
that the whole thing could fall over
next month um and i think so that i
think is another danger then you have uh
the international situation um uh we
haven't paid as much attention to it as
we might have done because of other
things going on but but you know
tensions between the u.s and china over
taiwan are ramping up quite dramatically
there's a call between president biden
and president xi today but you know it
is coming to something when uh
nancy pelosi the u.s speaker house of
representatives is saying that the
military is worried about her visiting
taiwan in case the chinese shoot down
the plane of someone who is in the
direct line of succession for the
presidency i mean this is
a sign of how serious that situation is
so i think whoever becomes prime
minister is going to face a remarkable
set of challenges
that was quite telling in the talk tv
debate that we had this week that one of
the first questions was about the
national health service and this is the
first time that both candidates had
really been pressed in one of these
leadership debate formats on the on the
nhs um and it was very clear that
neither sudanac nor trusts had a
comprehensive answer to the waiting list
which are currently at 6.6 million on
nhs england and our forecast to go up to
if we're lucky
9 million by march 2024 it could be
closer to 10 million they were talking
about efficiency gains they were talking
about technology but
frankly
i felt like i was watching them squirm a
bit because it was just very clear that
they didn't have an answer to this
terrible crisis now on our hands
i think one thing is clear but the
waiting list is going to end up being
higher than people expect because this
has been a difficult few months for the
nhs because you've had these repeated
little coveted waves that just have made
it hard i think to make much progress in
terms of dealing with the backlogs um
plus you've had the kind of consequence
of of the extreme weather
then i think
if you add to this that you know yes
there is the backlogs issue and i think
that you know that there's going to
risky soon after argument is who i've
known for years his argument is look i
put up national insurance to put my
money into the nhs because essentially
if the waiting list is is is 10 million
by the time in the next election you
know that is politically unviable but
even if you set aside the question of
what the waiting list will be by the
time the next election is how does the
nhs cope with this winter i think is is
it
it is beginning to be a real growing
warrior whitehall
i know
far more short-term question uh james in
your column you talk about how if the
tory leadership race had had a bit more
breathing space
lots of different things could have
happened perhaps kemi bednak would have
had more time to make her case uh she
might have gotten more mp support we
could have seen
a host of things happening um but you
also point out that one of the
consequences of that lack of breathing
space
is that there's very little time to
think about the challenges ahead and how
the tories might secure a fifth term it
seems as if a lot of the decisions
they're going to have to make around
really serious issues are are going to
be rushed
so in this context kemi madnock was kind
of
i think one of the things that attracted
me to our candidacy she was arguing that
you know the tory police should start
arguing from first principles about what
it wants to achieve but frankly the
timetable set for this contest does not
does not give you enough time to do that
and i think whatever criticisms you make
of a timetable and and it is clearly
very compressed i think the the the the
calculation that you know the country
would not take kindly to the tory party
having a uh having a leadership contest
in september say given the number of
problems coming down the track is i
think probably right i mean the public
would think well hang on a second don't
need a government right now
and there isn't a lot of time to
scrutinize i mean in some ways you can
argue yes we're having a lot of
accountability because every television
network is hosting its own debate we're
going to have the hustings but i'm just
reminded as we go through this
leadership race how many topics and
areas of public policy there are to get
through and some of them aren't even
getting a look in for example this week
nadine doris the big backer boris
johnson who's now supporting liz truss
and her leadership bid insisted on radio
4 that liz trust continues to support
her online harms bill which you know has
raised monumental questions about free
speech in the uk and the consequences of
of this bill and what it could do to
free speech online but we don't even
have time to really get into this or to
discuss it uh because as for all the
reasons you just pointed out this is a
very hurried campaign yeah i think the
big question is does the bill
proceed
as is with the legal but harmful section
in or does the legal or harmful section
drop out while it's the measures in the
bill to to protect children online stay
i thought it's quite interesting that
when the spectator did um it's hustings
with the candidates that kind of liz
trust
wasn't um
penny morgan was saying you know that
she was basically in favor of the bill
as it stands liz trust was saying that
she wants to kind of work with people on
on the free speech elements of it uh but
i think it is quite difficult to do that
if you keep this whole concept of legal
but harmful in that
james um last question there seems to be
an unspoken problem although perhaps liz
trust has tried to speak to it and
gotten quite a bit of pushback which is
that regardless of what plans the
candidates come up with whether that be
more subsidies to help people through
the winter whether it be liz truss's
program of tax cuts
whatever it may be
neither candidate if they go into
downing street is going to have the
lever the most important one that you
can pull to get inflation under control
that lies with the bank of england
that's interest rates and lewis trust
has been more critical of the bank of
england she's been talking about looking
at its remit
i'm not convinced that changing its room
it will change much at all given the
fact that the bank is supposed to be
targeting two percent inflation right
now and we're on track for double digits
they have haven't seemed to take it oh
so seriously um without that lever
the candidates can talk about what
they're going to do for inflation all
they want but the hard truth is that
their hands are actually a bit tied
yeah i i think that obviously on
interest rates as you say is it's the
bank of england that determines what
they are i think there's also another
another complication here which is
central bank independence is is regarded
as so important by the markets but i
think it is i think it is very risky if
you try and
change the bank's mandate in a kind of
mechanistic fashion if you so i mean you
know if x happens you must do y i i i
think that you know i mean i i think
whatever mistakes the bank of england
may have made
um and and clearly as you say given
where inflation is some mistakes have
been made i think i would be very wary
of what the consequences for for example
the value of sterling would be
or of of of politicians interfering that
directly in what the bank is doing
james thanks for joining me
the spectator's former editor charles
moore spoke to rishi cenac for this
week's issue was tsunak rude to trust in
that bbc head-to-head debate is he an
advocate of political and economic
orthodoxy or is he a real reformer
and is he really a natural heir to
margaret thatcher here's a snippet of
their conversation
do you think that that we face a crisis
in the west
which our leaders are not really facing
up to
primarily but not only because of the
massive threat of china
yes i think china is a significant
threat to us and
you know i talked about it yesterday
it's a threat to our economic security
and thereby our national security and we
need to be robust in defending ourselves
against that i i think you're right i
think we you know i think there is a
complacency about this and i've worked
and lived around the world
and i mentioned it in the maze lecture
you know our ability to project power
and influence and to make a difference
in the difference in the world is is in
large part a function of the strength of
our economy
and you know ultimately if we want to
fund the armed forces if we want to make
sure that we can make a difference in
countries around the world it all starts
with having a very strong vibrant
growing economy which is why getting
that right is critical to all these
things because there's only so much we
can rely on
history and nostalgia to project our
power we need actually raw power and
that comes
first of all from economic strength now
the the thing i see and it goes back to
the debate in this leadership election
is are we prepared to work at it or not
right are we prepared to do what all
these other countries are doing which is
have a time horizon that is far longer
than ours they are all prepared to
sacrifice in the short term yeah because
they want to do something that in their
it advances their interests in the long
term they are prepared to sacrifice they
are prepared to work hard you saw you
see all that in china you see that you
see it in russia right they prepared for
this for a very long time right and
we have to ask ourselves are we prepared
to do the same can we look forward to
richie soon at belton road initiative
yeah well well that's
well so our economic strength is
important to making sure that we can
counter initiatives like that but it's
or that our military strength can be
projected but i think there's something
more fundamental we have to have the
hunger that we have no right to a seat
at that top table we have no right to
project our force and our values more
importantly across the world we have to
earn it
and the things that are worth having
require hard work and sacrifice but i
tell you they are sweeter as a result
but it's an entirely conservative
value i think to to sacrifice in the
short term as my family did for a very
different reason to put in the hard work
to build a better future and if we want
to meet these threats from countries
like china from russia and others
we need to get ourselves into that
mindset as a country so these arguments
that i'm making in a micro sense on
taxing and borrowing uh can actually be
expanded to a much larger thing are we
prepared to earn the success that we
need in order to succeed in the world
and that is a critical question right
and it's not easy for people to hear
that and as as leader it's my
responsibility to get our country in a
position to do that thank you one very
quick last question um you praised mr
satchel but you probably don't like this
quotation
um particularly because you are up
against a strong woman and she said um
the [ __ ] may crow but the hen lays the
eggs
what do you what how do you react to
that well you know what i i'm the dad
first and foremost regardless of this
job i'm the dad of two young girls so
the more amazing female role models they
have uh the better i think there was a
lovely story i can't remember it was in
your book or was it in one of hers where
she was visiting a school at some point
a primary school somewhere in the late
80s
and
she was asking the kids it was a boy
about you know what did he want to do
when he grew up and i can't remember
what he said and then she said
and then she said or do you not want to
be prime minister and he said oh can
boys do that
and i thought that was brilliant right
so
uh yeah you know as a dad of two young
girls you know i said but this boy can
do it this boy can do it against a woman
right
you're talking about me yes yes
absolutely i can yes absolutely i can
and look you've seen great female role
models in this campaign whether it's
kemi whether it's penny whether it's uh
whether it's liz but you know i believe
i'm the right person to do this job at
this time we have enormous challenges
facing the country you know i will bring
a different type of leadership and it's
leadership that will make sure that we
are fit for the future and i'm doing
this motivated by a set of conservative
values that i hold dear that i am
passionate about that i was raised with
because of what this country did for my
family that's what i will bring to this
office and we will deliver a
conservative government that makes an
enormous difference to people's lives
remember if you enjoy what we do here at
the spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content to
subscribe today go to spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash tv offer
former diplomat charles parton writes in
this week's magazine that while the west
is finally getting its head around the
challenges posed by china we're ignoring
the biggest problem of all their control
over the internet of things are we about
to usher in a chinese communist party
surveillance state within our own
borders charlie joins me now
charles you write in your piece for the
magazine this week that while
politicians now recognize china's
challenge to our security they're still
ignoring one of the most significant
threats from the chinese communist party
can you explain
yeah i mean full credit to our
politicians but they've actually got at
last they got their uh um ideas in line
on huawei and they've certainly begun to
get the idea of the importance of
semiconductors but what they haven't
really focused on is the internet of
things which is in a sense far greater
threat than
what's being delivered by china to r5g
and and so
the basis of the piece that i've put out
in the spectator this week is to say
this is a really serious problem uh
internet of things the internet of
things these these modules are
going to be even more um
throughout our both not just our home
lives but are more importantly our our
industrial life uh and it's um a really
a great threat to us that if if those
uh if china seeks to which it is seeking
to dominate the um production of the
internet of things i mean three chinese
companies at the moment already have 54
of the global market and that's 75 of
the actual connections between these
devices
and their aim is to
to to dominate that which will then give
them not just economic power because
these are the industries of the future
but but geopolitical power and that's a
great threat to our national security
the the economic prosperity of our
companies our privacy and data and to
our values and so i think we've got to
take urgent action against it and
charles can for our audience can you
just break down what exactly the
internet of things is
yes i mean the these are our our modules
that um
are in many ways quite self-sufficient i
mean they they they connect with each
other they have sensors they have
software they have processors they they
communicate
and they're able to um exchange and
process vast amounts of data at a very
quick speed um with without very much
human
engagement and so so they're going to be
controlling many of our our processes
our supply chains our manufacturing our
agricultural transport you know urban
planning security you name it um
and
so so we really really must ensure that
they don't have in them the ability to
transmit all that data back to beijing
so it's basically that it's the digital
infrastructure behind all of our
institutions that make society work
right and these these cellular modules
are in many things whether that's in in
hick vision cameras or or or
much of the equipment that that china
supplies in in in a number of sensitive
areas
and even if
when they're put in they're relatively
clean and you can you can perhaps check
that they're patched patched with
software on a very regular basis and
there's no way on earth that that anyone
can check whether a malware is not being
put into that
and the other thing is that all this
data goes back and goes on to the cloud
again where is that going to be stored
well one hopes within our own countries
or within friendly countries but again
that's that that those clouds are
vulnerable to attack
uh and we may send it to third countries
because they they deal very cheaply with
it more perhaps more cheaply but how
good is their security so i think we've
got to be really much more careful uh in
how we handle this
charles let's turn the perspective a bit
here what is the end goal for g in all
this
well she's been quite clear if you they
have what they call the second
centennial goal which is that china
should be a modernized civilized
socialist country a strong country by
2049 the 100th anniversary of its of the
founding of the people's republic but
translate that from from party speak
what it really means is that china would
be the number one superpower uh america
number two and the world would be so
ordered in its government so ordered
that it suits the interests of the
chinese communist party and and and
there are ways in which th that he's
going around it and as i say in in the
article
it's not just the economic sticks and
carrots diplomacy which we're used to
and massive investment in foreign
propaganda and interference to the
united front but one of the main and
perhaps the most important way of doing
it is to dominate the new technologies
if you dominate those it's not just the
economic rents that you'll get from them
but you'll be able to exert very
considerable pressures geopolitical
pressures on the countries which are
using your your new technologies
so we've we've got to um and as i said
earlier the the internet of things is is
perhaps
one of the most if not the most
important
of these new technologies
charlie we do need to address the
balance of security with economic
prosperity at least in the short term
because if the west is going to push to
further decouple from china that is
going to come with serious economic
consequences yes first of all let me
just say that decoupling is is happening
at both ends it's not just the british
or the americans or the western
countries that are decoupling china
itself is is decoupling i mean i mean
it's it has its dual circulation uh
policy and and xi jinping
has been really quite clear on on the
need for self-sufficiency etc which is
another word for decoupling um
and and decoupling i'm afraid is is
going to
harm the global economy uh there's no
doubt about that but uh in in the longer
term i think people have to consider uh
do we take um
a smallish a smaller
economic hit or are we in the longer
term going to submit
our our values our security
and the longer term prosperity of our
companies actually which are being
deliberately hollowed out i mean if you
take this uh internet of things these
manufacturers cellular models actually
they're quite a lot of um companies
which
in the free and open countries
which manufacture these uh and we should
be uh in encouraging them because if we
don't the the clear aim is is that the
three chinese companies will
cut them out and and kill them off just
as they killed off you know
enormous companies the world's leading
um
telecommunications company nortel was
deliberately killed off um by espionage
and other unfair chinese practices so
the long term
economic cost
vastly outweighs the short-term costs of
decoupling um neither is is in our is
good for us but one is a lot smaller
than the other charlie what do you make
of the two final leadership candidates
rishi sunak and liz trust and their
position on china they seem to almost be
battling it out now for who has the
tougher stance
yes i i mean one welcomes the fact that
they've woken up to the chinese threat i
don't see the need for them to attack
each other on that i mean i think that
the measures that uh rishi sunak
uh set out in his in in his recent uh
uh press release uh and we could go into
the detail of that if you wish but but
basically uh it is indeed to tackle the
particularly the scientific threat to
our science and technology those
measures are entirely sensible and one
would hope that um mistrust would would
support them rather than uh engage in in
arguments with with
sunakuster who who moved first uh the
point is they're moving that's great
charlie thanks
and finally has the right gone too far
in the culture wars the spectators
associate editor douglas murray says
that perhaps it isn't wise to use the
left's tactics to explain douglas joins
me now
douglas great to see you on spectator tv
you write in your column for the
magazine this week about how the right
is retaliating against the culture wars
in the united states tell us about it
yes well as i mentioned in in the piece
there's been an inevitable backlash
brewing for some years
the left has been able for years to
accuse people of racism homophobia
misogyny and much more with absolute
impunity uh
you don't have to back up the claims you
don't have to prove it people say well
if it's not true then why not sue and
the answer is
how can you sue and end up in a court of
law over somebody's claim on twitter
particularly if you're just in a private
individual so this has been going on for
years we've all known it we've all seen
it uh as it's as it's been growing and
i've always said it's inevitable that at
some point people would find an
accusation to level back
and that's now arrived it's arrived in
the u.s in the form of the term groomer
some people may not be uh familiar with
this not everyone follows the uh online
and offline culture wars that closely
but groomer is a very interesting
accusation that the writers started to
play back
um and it's as i say in the piece it's
got some sense to it which is the only
thing that our society actually does
abhor even more than racism is
child abuse
so leveling child abuse accusations of
somebody is is a is a is a good way as
it were to hit somebody hard and low
and in the last few months in particular
segments of the american right have
realized that this is a very personal
accusation and one which they can use
back at portions of the left now how did
this come about i trace it among other
things to a strange corner of the
culture war which you know kate which
happened about a year ago which was um
around about something called drag queen
story hour and drag queen story hour was
the discovery that some school children
were being read stories in a library by
a drag queen
um it became a huge sort of culture war
issue and segments of the right
particular religious rights said this is
this is basically sodom and gomorrah
this is this is this is babylon um and
and much more but then people started to
keep an eye on among other things the
way in which pride month
and other
segments of the what's now become
lgbtqia plus agenda
um started to move into the mainstream
so for instance parents bringing their
children to pride events which in my
view in many cases is totally
inappropriate
starting to see children at events they
shouldn't be at uh the right started to
say things like
aha
you this is a groomer event
um it happened with for instance some
teaching in schools about
gender fluidity about a hundred genders
and all this sort of thing stonewall the
british uh charity which i think is a
lamentable organization now uh uh just
last week put out a tweet saying that
two-year-olds should know their gender
identity and
and basically segments of the right have
realized not just that there is
something crazy about assuming that even
a two-year-old can say you know i'm
gender non-conforming or i'm a lesbian
or i'm gay or i'm trans or anything else
what do you know at two for god's sake
uh um not just that this is crazy to be
teaching children this but that a
shortcut to stopping it is to level this
accusation
groomer
douglas the way that you talk about okay
groomer in the piece suggest that you're
not terribly impressed with the use of
the term
as you just pointed out there there
might be examples that understandably
deeply frustrate or worry sensible
people but that the accusation itself
is just making the culture wars worse
and it's taking us to a place in our
conversations where we cannot have any
kind of conversation back and forth that
doesn't result in the nastiest most ugly
accusations going back and forth
that's right i i do actually fear that i
i think that i think one of the
questions which i've written about in
the magazine in the past of recent years
has been how do you respond to an
accusation um
which is not disprovable and the
accusation of racism is not disprovable
i mean a person can't get it off them if
it's if they're accused of it uh they
can say well you know i'm i've got black
friends or i i'm not racist or i'm
married to a
black woman or whatever whatever they
say they still can't get it off them
even people who are black can't get the
accusation of racism off them and this
is this is very um
it causes an enormous amount of anger
and frustration to people i think that
groomer is a sort of accusation back at
a similar level and i do worry about the
results of it i worry about the results
of it not least because you can see a
situation where two political sides both
throw the nastiest dirtiest accusations
against each other and you sort of can't
get them off the second reason i worry
about it is that i do think there's
going to be a and i mention this in the
piece
the the the
portions of um you know the sort of
what's called the lgbtqia plus world are
going to get caught up in this they just
already are and a lot of gay people who
don't want anything to do with the
gender nonsense don't want anything to
do with you know uh drag queens
strippers and children being present
don't want anything to do with any of
this are going to get caught up in it
so that's the second reason but a third
reason is just really about a commitment
to truth which is that you always have
that option i actually wrote about this
last week in the magazine
you always have that option don't you in
any political discussion of
um will i or will i not abandon my
commitment to truth
um will i just grab the nearest thing
the nearest stick and just beat my
opponent with it or will i actually
resist that urge
and as i've written in the magazine
before in american politics today a very
distinct urge is not just to defeat your
opponent but to hurt them to really hurt
them that's one of the one of the things
about the donald trump phenomenon is
seizing donald trump as a weapon to hurt
your opponents uh the democrats do that
the other way around as well so it all
sites are guilty of it there's always
this moment of
should i do that or try to do that and i
am as you say kate i am concerned about
it because i do think that although
there are occasions where you can say
actually you know this is deeply
inappropriate for children for instance
there are some teachers that have been
captured on things like libs of tick
tock saying things that they teach their
class that are completely inappropriate
which actually could fall into the into
the category of being groomer-like
behavior so i'm not saying that this
doesn't exist at all i think that it's a
a specific accusation like the
accusation of racism that should be
reserved for specific um justifiable
occasions
what i worry about
is a decision by as i say people who
want to win a culture you want to say
actually we're going to give up on that
we're just going to level it as hard and
often as we can and that'll show them
and douglas another point you
quite thoughtfully make i think in your
pieces is that this seems to be a blown
up from a storm in the teacup that drag
queen story hour was not happening in
every school across the united states um
and actually as you point out in the
magazine you know there's something
quite lovely and nice in many
circumstances about drag queens and
their performances and
pen to mine
well sure i mean that's that's that's
one very family friendly example um but
that you know if we wrap this all up
together we're actually in danger of
taking what again most nice sensible
people can judge for themselves as
appropriate or not appropriate for
children and we're just putting
disgusting labels on it and and that's
wrong too i mean that's the antithesis
of being progressive and and you know i
think on the right and the left you can
be progressive um you know you you can
you can be open-minded and we're
basically just trying to lump it all in
together and shut it all down for the
sake as you say beating the other side
up
yeah well i'm not particularly
interested in being progressive myself
fair enough to each their own um but but
you know i
the general point here just being that
um you know we've come a long way as a
society when it comes to accepting other
people's sexual orientations and being
open-minded to adults doing you know
what it is that they want to do as long
as you're not harming anybody else and
we are in danger of taking what is
objectively bad behavior but often very
specific
and and very narrow and just trying to
put labels on everything that it doesn't
need a label we don't need to get
involved
well
yeah what i'd say is that what's
actually going on is it's classic
in-group out-group behavior
um
an out-group discovers an in-group
behavior and and worries about it
there's a combination of that which as i
say the internet is particularly good
and useful for as a tool
and the second thing is the undoubted
example of that that does exist
particularly in america of children
being subjected to things that they just
shouldn't be subjected to they shouldn't
be made aware of they're far too young
it's it's it's it's ridiculous there's
always a worry about children and such
than the sexualization of children it's
a completely legitimate and
understandable fear it's a fear all
parents have it's a it's a fear that
society should have are we sexualizing
children too young that's an absolutely
legitimate fear of a society and so when
things blow up around children it's
completely understandable um and there
should be a debate about what is taught
in school there should be a debate about
inappropriate things shown to children
and every parent knows this and every
school should know this and school
should be responsive to parent fears uh
but i do think that there is a um a
specific a specific corner of this which
is um potentially highly inflammatory
and if i can just say so quickly
one example of how inflammatory it is is
that twitter which is effectively as
much as we might resist it the de facto
town square twitter has banned the use
of the word groomer on the platform now
and that's very interesting because this
speaks also to this pent-up anger that
is that is brewing on elements of the
right twitter has not banned the use of
the left's favorite cudgels it has not
said you know
any labour mp who accuses boris johnson
of racism is going to have their tweet
taken down it doesn't say that no no no
still allows the
false accusations it could be leveled by
the left primarily by the left to be
allowed whilst trying to silence the
false accusations mainly false
accusations made by people on the right
that's that's an example of the
exacerbation of a problem that i think
we're going to see more of
i'd like to think that through very
delicate issues like this issues of
sexuality particularly issues around
children i'd like to think that our
societies could have these arguments out
sensibly uh reasonably and with due
concern
for the health and well-being of
children i would i would think that the
least likely way to have that debate is
to accuse any and all opponents of being
child abusers but that's where we are
and if you want to as i say in the piece
if you want to see a little glimpse into
the 2020s political debate you can see
an unending war where two sides both
level knowingly false accusations
against the other
you know douglas i i really despair
because i feel like if the right and the
republican party institutionally goes
down this road of trying to match the
left you know punch for punch on the
culture war it's going to undermine
other fundamental values it has i
remember ron desantis not so long ago in
response to drag queen hour talking
about how he was considering getting
social services involved if there were
any evidence that a parent were to
introduce their child to a drag queen or
take their kid to a drag queen show now
you and i might have opinions of
everybody will have opinions about what
is appropriate at certain ages
and we should be able to have that
discussion but i was quite shocked to
see a republican governor
talking about taking one's child away
from them i mean we are talking about
like the most core fundamental frankly
american values about
family and your children and that
parents come first not the state
and
you know we have to be able to have
these conversations without trying to
use the tools of the state
to attack our opponents and
personally i think this is a an element
of the trump era that has come to
dominate the republican party that
actually you play as dirty as your
opponent and you use the tools at your
disposal um you know and i lament it i
i'd be interested on your thoughts on
this
yeah no i i think that's an interesting
point i mean i think desantis was
specifically referring to i mean some
videos that emerged of
uh children being taken to like strip
shows basically where uh they're being
encouraged to put money into the pants
of uh a a drag queen stripper
and and that's that's the sort of thing
that quite understandably enrages a lot
of people people saying like what are
they doing there why would the parents
be taking them to this and again i'm
sorry to return to it but again
the
whole gay uh world is going to get
caught up in this if
no kind of boundaries whatsoever are
exercised
um but so desantis i if i remember
rightly was responding to
videos like that but you're right kate
that i mean a normal conservative
response would have been look
uh um
we will advise parents not to to be so
irresponsible as to take children such a
thing we will of course
expect that schools wouldn't knowingly
put children through any such thing
um but but no i mean you wouldn't you
wouldn't intervene at the level of
social services but you're right kate
this is a discovery of parts of the
american right recently which is that
they can use the tools back at their
opponents their opponents are basically
used against them and that includes you
know using the tools of the state and
much more um this is going to get very
ugly and
as i say i mean uh a very delicate
social issues need to be dealt with you
know basically very fine tuning
um parents have to be um have to be
encouraged to good behavior they
shouldn't be brow beaten into it they
certainly shouldn't be threatened by the
state into it um and everyone is gonna
have to kind of cool it a bit i think
but um why would you call it if you've
just discovered a cudgel uh so
incredibly effective why would you cool
it when you're standing over your
opponent uh with a cudgel that you've
long wished to wield douglas my last
question to you is actually about the
start of your piece for the magazine
this week to talk about the culture war
a bit more generally you start by
writing about a billboard in southwark
in london which has written on it hey
straight white men pass the power
now southwark is one of the most
deprived local authorities in the
country and the question that
immediately pops into my head is what is
being achieved with that poster can the
left not see the extent to which that
alienates people and
you know to expand this can the right
and the left not at this point see the
extent to which just
normal people who perhaps aren't even
that political look at these crazy
accusations on both sides and think to
themselves i want nothing to do with
that they're not going to open their
mind they're not going to learn any
lessons from these accusations
no this billboard in southwark is is a
pure provocation
um it's by a black artist from marseille
um uh it's it's obviously approved by uh
the local authorities you can't put up
uh posters and and public works
billboards and things without going
through approval processes
as i say i think that if a billboard
said hey black guys give us your rights
or oy gays hand over the cash oh i would
like that no one would like it everybody
would condemn it everyone would say it
was racist and so far as i can see apart
from me nobody has uh noticed this or
bothered about a sign
in a in the public square
that just insults straight white men and
accuses them of being powerful and
as you say kate i mean you know
imagine if imagine being a an ordinary
straight white male in southwark
and being told on top of everything else
on top of all the others sufferings
deprivations
unknown
tragedies you've gone through in your
life you're powerful you've got power
and you've got to hand it over
at at a point of a kind of threat
um
what what is achieved by this only one
thing which is a digging in of a feeling
of resentment uh and you know the mayor
of london
southwark council everyone else who
approves this kind of behavior this kind
of provocation should really be asked to
rethink this
why does it make sense to keep insulting
majority populations most people in
britain are white
most people are heterosexual
half the population is male
why the hell would you do this other
than to just hurt people and i'm afraid
the answer is there's no other reason
it's just
that
douglas thanks for joining spectator tv
and that's it for this week remember if
you enjoy what we do here at the
spectator you can subscribe to the
magazine and to our online content join
today and you'll pay just one pound a
week for unlimited online and app access
in your first year to subscribe today go
to spectator dot co dot uk forward slash
tv offer
and don't forget to subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel just click
the subscribe button at the bottom of
this video and tap the bell icon to make
sure you never miss an episode thanks
again for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you